so so take a look at this
take a look at this so our buddy biden
becomes president
right when he becomes president he goes
on a
executive order frenzy right big time
and he said in an interview i think it
was last year when they asked him they
said
what do you think about executive orders
he said i think executive orders
if you do it without asking the other
side you're a dictator what's the
difference between a dictator and
someone so this is
he says this in an interview you can see
this it's everything it was that
interview
less than a year ago wow that's what it
was right give or take a year ago
so he becomes a president day one
executive order paris climate change
ending ban on u.s entry from majority
muslim countries
requiring mass squaring on federal
property coordinating a
a government-wide covenanting response
incorporating
undocumented immigrants into census
refusing refocusing on climate crisis
and cancelling the keystone keystone xl
permit which was
massive uh mandating ethics ethics
pledge for government appointees
polling funds from border wall pausing
federal student loan payments
strengthening deferred action for
childhood arrivals
promoting covet 19 safety and domestic
and international travel
expanding access to cover 19 treatments
established in a coca-19 pandemic
testing board
guaranteeing unemployment insurance for
workers who refuse work due to covet 19
facilitating delivery for stimulus
payments empowering
federal workers and contractors
okay reversing transgender military ban
reinstating coven 19 travel restrictions
promoting buy
america agenda and reliance on private
prisons
initiating plan to combat climate change
by the way i'm not done re-establishing
presidential council on science and
technology we've got like 10 pages
i mean i can keep going you know
reinforcing medicaid and affordable
health care act okay
35 executive orders seven memorandums
and three proclamations and if you pull
up the history of who's had
the most executive orders this is what
you would find okay go
up so here's the leaders in executive
orders
biden okay go up a little bit so i can
read exactly what the timeline biden's
fury
flurry of executive orders stand outs in
his first two weeks president biden has
signed more executive orders
uh uh most recent presidents did in
their first month he has signed nearly
as many executive orders as fdr did in
his record-breaking month so
fdr did 30 biden the 28.
look who's third obama is third at what
16.
you take trump out who's fourth true
truman now watch this why did i say if
you take trump out here's why
the left typically likes to enforce
through force
we're doing this whether you like it or
not is the left right the right wants to
uh truman was a democrat yes
no now watch this now watch this now
watch this trump is at 12.
what does that say about trump trump's
not a republican
people don't realize trump was never a
republican
trump is independent trump was a
democrat for most of his career
now he's a republican for the last
however long decade of his career
trump stole the 12 executive orders that
is an independent you look at the rest
bush 7 clinton six
g.h w bush senior two he was just like
i'm not even having any executive orders
in the first 30 days reagan five carter
left seven ford five on the right
nixon five on the right johnson left
seven
kennedy left seven eisenhower right
six truman left 13. this tells you
about how they look at executive orders
so what does this have to do what we
were talking about earlier
with uh with what do you call it with uh
wall street bets
if um if the right people want to just
go out and create a new law
and push wall street bets around they
can easily do it
you know why most of these guys on the
left were funded by wall street
so if you get funded by wall street you
have to kind of realize just like the
company we talk about robin hood which
is what
you campaign for the little person the
small people
the people that don't have don't have
the money but you report to who
the people that people give you big
money of course wall street people they
give you the big money
these there's no no different here you
you campaign
we gotta help the but you have to report
to the people that funded
your campaign and if you don't make that
phone call
and the campaign people call you and say
hey listen we gave you this much money
here's what you need to do here
we need a law we need barrier to enter
papa papa we need somebody to go look at
wall street bets and investigate and we
need somebody
that's how this thing works i am fully
on wall street's bedside i'd like 100
percent
what do you mean of course you are 100
but you need contacts so
hopefully these shamats and musks and
all these other guys are so on their
side that they protect them
hopefully that's what they need right
that's basically come out and said that
he's on this
on this team and he donated uh yeah half
an hour
yeah he did five does this thing yeah uh
so with with uh
i mean i don't know how much time you
want to spend on biden's exactly we have
like 12 pages
go forward you know i went through some
of these
and let me give you i guess my
perspective on this i went
uh there's probably four pages i don't
disagree with a lot of these things
yeah you know so let me give you two
sides of the coin here on biden
number one he came out there and he said
what's the quote that you said if you do
too many executives you're dictating
orders you're you're a dictator yeah at
the same time he's
just reversing a lot of what trump just
did so rever trump came in reversed a
lot of what obama did
obama uh uh yeah but so many other
presidents can do the same thing totally
with you but he's doing it more than
what
what's the one thing in common with who
fdr when he was the president in 1933
what's what are they worldwide they had
a crisis they just had a freaking they
just got out of the great depression in
the middle of the great depression now
they're in world war ii
so biden because again this is in the
first
month of the presidency right this is
what this stat is
trump came in and there wasn't a lot to
quote unquote change he did it
you know in my opinion a lot of it out
of spite a lot of it of like
well obama did this i'm doing this yeah
biden is coming in a lot of his
mask mandates you know executive orders
on climate crisis you know obviously
he's no fan of big uh
big oil um a lot of it is covered
related exactly the other side won't you
ask the other side well that's the my
next point trust the other side why
don't you just say hey guys if it's not
that big of a deal why don't you ask him
i don't know how that works within
congress but yes his hope it's not a big
deal why don't you ask him and sit down
say guys here's what i want to what do
you think about it yeah
and let them say we disagree okay i'm
going to do it anyway how long does that
take though
because this this political politically
it could take weeks so so this is
years to get something done listen for
me
here's here's like my approach you know
tico and dylan get into it okay did you
guys try to address it with each other
no i don't want to talk to them i can't
help you
talk to each other yeah get in a room
and figure it out then come out and
still do the executive order i'm good
because now you can say what look i went
in the room and i talked to
we tried to talk about they didn't want
to talk to me yeah okay cool the people
gonna say
you know what fine but you at least made
what
the effort that hey here's where we are
this is what i want to do you know you
can't
drop the word unity and not do that so
for example if your campaign
jimmy carter's campaign was what human
rights okay
and he targeted two countries iran and
cuba okay
human rights late 70s late 70s human
rights human rights if that's your
campaign
you better advance that campaign trump's
campaign was what
build the wall build a wall build a wall
build a wall make but it was build the
wall
build the wall build the wall guess what
he started building the wall
right that's what i need to do taxes
build a wall etcetera
he said what he's going to do great if
you say unify you got to unify
you but so then don't say unify
obama said what change change to what
change of philosophy change of what
obamacare health care
guess what he kept his commitment
of i'm going to go out there make change
now he got up and said it's not going to
cost you
a penny we're not going to tax you you
can keep your plan if you're watching
that was not the truth
it wasn't a true but he did make drastic
changes
scary changes for some people on the
other side but he kept his commitment
you can't say unify is that is that
basically your point here on biden is
that you're saying let's i'm going to be
the president for all these people
we're known as the centrist you're the
centrist you're let's just say you're a
center left guy etc
okay great show a little bit now he's
coming in as a dictator now he's
essentially
he's coming in on what he called the
dictator not what i call a dictator
his interpretation of a dictator i never
said he's a dictator
he said he's a dictator that's what
biden called is it the fact that
um you don't agree with some of the
executive actions or just the fact that
he's making executive actions
regardless of what the uh actions are
you understand my question is it
i just don't like that he's doing
executive actions or i don't like
exactly what they
are no less there's a little bit of both
if trump came out and says i'm going to
do
all executive orders and you do well you
said you were going to do that
yeah so just you said you're going to do
that then do that
it's all good we knew he was going to do
that so the people who voted for him
guess what they wanted
a bunch of what executive orders and he
did it
this guy didn't come out saying i'm
going to do a bunch of executive orders
gotcha
okay he did say a couple but he didn't
come out saying like he said climate you
know
day one i'm gonna do periscope minimum
wage he did say those things
totally fine yes but this many a little
bit a little bit that's aggressive
it's a little aggressive on what's
aggressive so again the the the parlor
the robin hood the the the amount of
executive orders somehow someway they're
all tied to each other
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye